America's tragedy has a new face
that of Virginia school teacher Abby's
Werner said to be showing signs of
improvement after being left critically
injured in yet another U.S school
shooting
a depressingly familiar tale with one
crucial difference the shooter was just
six years old
well-wishers have been pouring in from
his Werner from across America
James Madison University where she was a
student said it was deeply saddened by
the reported tragic shooting of JMU
alumna Abby's Werner we offer prayers
and best wishes for Abby's health and
Recovery local police said the incident
didn't appear to be an accident the
altercation was between a six-year-old
the student who did have the firearm and
the teacher and then around was fired
like I said she suffered a gunshot wound
and has been transported to the hospital
no one else was hurt in the shooting the
relief visible on the faces of families
who rushed to the scene after hearing
news that is now hauntingly familiar to
parents right across America somebody
had been shot at their child's School
everything goes to your mind you know
I'm a retired military
and so you know
you start for me it was a matter of okay
how do I get around
how do I get around where is she how do
I find her how do I get about what is it
going to take to do that when I say my
my my brain was running wild my mandates
it was running wild the six-year-old is
now in custody but his age poses
problems for the justice system he's too
young to be tried as an adult and Too
Young even to be sent to juvenile
detention but not too young it would
seem to take a deadly weapon into his
classroom that said one British mother
at the school Gates is proof of a wider
problem come on think about it let's do
something we've got a new governor now
let's do something let's change it
you've got a beautiful country you've
got beautiful people but what's the
problem guns a sentiment no doubt
echoing once again Across America as the
nation's parents hold their children a
little tighter Matthew Thompson Sky News